we told you at the top of the show about
the civil war brewing among democrats
the left not satisfied with president
joe biden's leadership his own party
wants a progressive primary challenger
one person whose name is being floated
marianne williamson
she ran for the nomination last time
debated by it and captured our attention
my first call is to prime minister of
new zealand who said that her goal is to
make new zealand the place where it's
the best place in the world for a child
to grow up and i will tell her
girlfriend you were so alone because the
united states of america is going to be
the best place in the world for a child
to grow up i'm going to harness love for
political purposes i will meet you on
that field and sir love will win
marianne williamson joins me now all
right so marianne are you considering
primarying president joe biden
no like many many people i'm thinking
very deeply about what's going on in
this country and i realize that the
horse race is not the conversation that
most matters you know to listen to fox
or listen to cnn to listen to msnbc it's
all about left versus right isn't it but
i don't think that that's the real
political divide that most matters in
this country i think that's kind of a
cartoonish version of the political
divide in this country that makes
billions of dollars for political forces
and media forces the real political
divide in this country jesse is between
the powerful and the powerless and the
powerful few are headquartered in both
major political parties it is the
corporate-backed forces whether it's big
pharmaceutical companies big oil
companies military defense contractors
etc that are
that are obstructing the financial
well-being and the greater economic and
uh uh professional and just personal
opportunities of the american people
that's what i would agree with that
there's definitely a big guy versus
little guy scenario and that's always
been the case and that's something this
country has to address in your opinion
as a progressive democrat if you still
label yourself like that where do you
think
president joe biden's biggest failures
have been so far in year one
not pushing back the biggest failures of
joe biden to me are the same as the
biggest photos of donald trump and
barack obama and every president in
modern history which is a refusal to
take on in any fundamental way the
dominance of these corporate forces i
mean if you look at the actual economic
opportunities of the average american
have they really been that different no
matter who now what this president could
do he could invoke a medical emergency
he could therefore expand medicare he
could override these vaccine patents so
the poor poor companies poor countries
could develop them he could cancel the
college loan he could
he could do so much he could free
assange he could decriminalize marijuana
there are so many things that could be
done with the power of the presidency
but what has happened is that the
presidency itself is such a partisan
thing the presidency no matter whether
it's a republican or a democrat should
stand unequivocally the president should
stand unequivocally for the rights and
the security and the well-being of the
american people one of the things that
you talked about versus right a lot in
the debates was harnessing the power of
love
how would you harness love
if you were president right now in 2022
well you know
lincoln talked about the angels of our
better nature the better angels of our
nature americans are people we've got
really wonderful things about us and
we've got some things about us you know
we're just human beings and some people
in this country harness anger harness
bigotry harness racism harness some of
the worst aspects of the american
character and what we need as a
president what we need is all of our
leaders to harness the nobility and the
intelligence and the decency and the
dignity of the american people and i
think too often politicians on both
sides of the aisle speak to the american
people like we're not as smart as we are
oh that's for sure and also continue to
foster this left-right divide rather
than than
really speaking to what is most deeply
wrong in this country and how we can
work together to fix it you know
eisenhower was a republican president
and he said that the the american mind
at its best is both liberal and
conservative there could be a lot more
cooperation okay well
the liberal part of my mind is very
little
it's a lot of conservative what part of
your mind is very little
wait what part of your mind is very
little the liberal part but that's okay
as long as there's a little bit it's
okay
that's okay but jessie our fellow
citizens
i gotta go the fact that okay and uh
thank you and thank you for coming on
waters world hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else